-That's how you
do it right there.
Maya Rudolph.
-Thank you, ladies.
-Looking gorgeous.
And, also, by the way,
also looking stunning over here
on the cover of
"Hollywood Reporter."
Ooh-la-la!
-Thanks, Jimmy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, my friend.
-I was reading about you in --
Well, I read this article,
but I want to say
it was a little gossip column.
-Oh, really?
-You were in the gossips.
You were in the papers.
-Oh, yes.
-You had a dinner with
Vice President Kamala Harris.
-I sure did. I sure did, Jimmy.
-Well, what was that like?
Because you never met her.
I know you did --
-First of all, I just want to
say, I didn't leak it.
Like, how does everybody know?
-Yeah.
No, you would never snitch.
-I don't want to be in trouble.
Like --
-Maya's not a rat.
You would never do that.
-I'm not a rat.
-No.
-Snitches get stitches.
-Exactly right, yes.
-And I -- There was
Secret Service everywhere.
So I was like, "I'm not guilty."
-Yeah. You're like,
"I'm forgetting
what I'm doing right now.
None of this happened." Yeah.
But what was it like?
-It was fantastic.
-You had never met her when --
-No -- Yeah,
I had only met her on Zoom.
And I say "only"
not like I was like,
"Oh, I can't wait to
meet Kamala Harris."
Like, it was a big deal.
-It was a big deal.
-But in the old days, when you
worked at "Saturday Night Live"
and you were doing
a political impression,
those people would
usually come through
the building, and you would
get to meet someone
you were impersonating.
But because it was COVID,
I never got to meet her.
But we did
a fundraiser together.
It was Amy Poehler, Hillary,
myself, and Kamala.
It was very cool.
-Wow!
-So I thought that was it,
and I was like, "I'm good."
It's great.
But then I got to go
to dinner with her
and the first
Second Gentleman, Doug.
-Doug.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-You got to meet Doug.
-I got to meet Doug.
Or I should say,
Doug got to meet me,
'cause he was pretty excited.
He was so nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He was like --
-He was -- he was so excited
that there were two Kamalas.
-Two Kamalas.
You had double --
Yeah, he loves his wife.
-He really loves his wife.
They love each other.
It's quite beautiful.
-Did she mention the impression
or you don't really
talk about it?
You just talk about --
-No, Doug mentioned it.
-He did?
-A lot. Yeah.
-He brought it up?
-Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh.
Do you get --
I mean, I've met people
I've impersonated before
and I kind of don't bring it up.
-Yeah, I don't like to mention
to people that I ape them.
"Hi. I ape you."
-I ape you, yeah.
-I mean, I do it for fun.
I'm, like, doing it
because you love the person.
You know.
It's like you're Mick Jagger.
It's, like, something
you would have been doing
in your bedroom anyway.
-Yeah.
-Or, like, in the shower.
-That's correct.
I would totally be doing that.
By the way, I saw you
at the season finale --
I saw you on the season finale
with Natasha Lyonne,
who was great.
-She was.
-And I didn't go to the show
because I kind of like
to stay --
I like to just watch the show.
-'Cause you don't like
going out at 11:30 at night
and getting up
at 4:00 in the morning?
-I'm too old.
I'm too old now
to stay up that late.
But, no,
I heard that, afterwards,
you had the after party
and you and some of
The Roots had a rager.
-Yes. My band, Princess,
got to play with
some of the these fine musicians
you're looking at right here.
-In the ice rink downstairs?
-In the ice rink,
where people ice-skate,
we got to play the after party.
-But I heard you crushed it.
It's, like,
a Prince tribute band.
-We are a
Prince tribute band, guys.
We are Princess.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Princess.
-Yes.
-I heard it was off the chain.
-It was really fun
because we brought
Wendy and Lisa out
from The Revolution,
from Prince's
original band, yeah.
-Didn't you freak out?
-Yeah.
I mean, Wendy and Lisa,
for me, are, like --
Like, I would daydream about
singing with them in my bedroom,
again, or in the shower
or in my car still, like --
-No, I mean, but seriously,
though, that's --
I know how much of
a fan you are.
-It's everything.
And, you know, it's Prince's
original, like -- It's his band.
It's the band that I connected
to his music with and to,
so I feel like
it's very personally --
life moment, full circle,
fulfilling.
-You're so talented.
I love you got to do that.
And -- Good.
It was, like, the best news.
I heard that, I'm like,
"Why was I not there?"
I was so jealous.
-It was pretty fun.
There was some -- People were
getting a little loose.
There was an older gentleman in
the front row all night.
-Yeah.
-Oh, really?
-All night.
-Oh, man.
Ooh, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-You know,
fans are excited about this.
Disney just released the first
photo to the upcoming sequel to
"Enchanted," called
"Disenchanted."
-"Disenchanted."
And it sounds fantastic,
because you play
the part of the villain.
-Yeah, with Amy Adams.
-I love Amy.
-So cool!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The coolest.
-Look at you.
You're playing the villain.
Is that fun to play the villain?
-Oh, my God, it's the most fun.
It's like --
-You can do everything.
-Yeah, you get to be, like,
arch and big and, like --
It's like, you know,
if anyone had ever said like,
"Oh, you get to be the villain,"
I'd be like,
"Oh, I'm --" You know,
when I first thought of
playing a villain,
I was like, "I don't want
to be the bad guy."
It's the most fun
you will ever have.
I have, like, a carriage
with horses and, like,
I got to be rude to people
and, like, I got a crown
and long nails.
And it was so fun.
-Disney knows
how to do it up, man.
-Oh, my God, it's the coolest
thing in the world.
A Disney villain?
-Yeah.
-I'm joining some serious ranks.
-And Amy Adams is fantastic,
by the way.
-Amy Adams
is basically perfection.
She's a perfect human being.
She's an unbelievable actress.
But, like,
I loved the first "Enchanted"
and I love Giselle,
the character she plays.
But I didn't realize --
I know Amy, but I didn't know
her as Giselle.
So, the first day
that I got to work,
she was already
in costume and makeup
and she started speaking to me
like Giselle.
And I found myself, like --
I felt like a little kid.
I was like...
-"You're a princess."
-Yeah, it felt like
being at Disneyland
and talking to a princess.
Her face is different somehow
when she's Giselle.
-Her eyes.
-Her eyes are twinkly.
And, like, her hands
are really beautiful.
And I felt like, "Okay."
-Yeah. And then you have to,
like, be the villain to her,
which is just so fun.
-It was real fun.
-Let's talk about "Loot"
and how funny this is.
Oh, my gosh.
I love the premise of it.
You are so good in this.
-Thank you, bud.
-There's so many good
little, like,
Maya Rudolphy aside jokes
that you're like,
"Oh, that is so funny"
that you have to, like,
watch it four times.
Even just the way you can
Moonwalk out of here,
and just, like,
that's not part of --
You do those little bits.
But who came up with
the idea for this?
-It was Alan Yang
and Matt Hubbard,
who I worked with
on a show called "Forever"
with our buddy Fred Armisen.
And they did "30 Rock"
and "Parks and Rec"
and they're great, great, great
writers.
And they just said to me like,
"How would you like to play
this woman
who is married to, like,
the most powerful man in the
world, and they get divorced.
They don't have a prenup,
so she's left with $87 billion."
-Billion dollars.
-It's like, "Great."
Yeah, billion with a "B."
-So, $87 billion.
And then she has to decide like,
"Hey, is this my life?
Like, do I like
this material life,
all these material things?"
-Yeah, or just, like --
I've been thinking about it
a lot because of the show.
Like, I think
we would all not be sad
to wake up with $87 billion.
But then, at the same time,
what enters my mind is like,
"And what are you
going to do with it?"
Like, a social responsibility
after you buy
like a couple islands.
-Yeah. Your character
is very conflicted
because she is
used to living that life
and swapping a champagne
for a fresher champagne.
-Exactly.
-And -- Yeah.
-It must be nice.
-It must be nice, yeah.
But it's super-fun, and I want
everyone to check it out.
It's on Apple TV+.
Here's a clip.
Here's Maya Rudolph in "Loot."
Take a look.
[ Buzzing ]
-Okay, great.
Well, we'll start with the
Howler Monkey
original hot sauce.
-Okay. This is so exciting.
♪♪
Mmm!
Tasty.
This is good. Mmm!
-So, the Wells Foundation --
tell me about some of
the things that
your organization
is focused on specifically.
-Of course.
One of the things that we're
very passionate about is -- Oh!
Ooh!
Wow. That one's got a little --
a little heat to it, doesn't it?
My goodness.
I'm just gonna have a little...
-Yeah, are you okay?
-I'm good.
I'm so sorry. It's so hot.
-Come on!
-He's amazing.
-He's brilliant.
Sean Evans is a genius.
I love that guy.
-I love him.
-We've had him on the show
a couple times,
and you have --
I mean, I only --
I mean, Da Bomb --
You make it to Da Bomb,
and, really,
that happens to your stomach.
And -- But he's so genius.
He takes his time with the
questions as you're sweating.
-He's unbelievable.
I can't -- He eats all of those
every single time.
-Yeah. He's the greatest.
Well, I can't
say he's the greatest
because Maya Rudolph is here.
Come on.
-Wait a minute. Guys!
-"Loot" premieres
this Friday on Apple TV+.